MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Hey, everyone.
Can you all hear me?
All right.
I hope you're having a good time
at Google I/O. We have a
fun presentation
for you today.
We're going to talk about
building data pipelines at
Google Scale.
My name is Michael
Manoochehri.
I'm a developer programs
engineer working primarily
with the Google BigQuery team.
And this talk is very near
and dear to my heart.
We're going to talk a little
bit about building data
processing applications
using some of
Google's cloud services.
This is going to be a good
talk for people that are
already building data processing
applications,
distributed data applications.
And if you're not very familiar
with the big data
space, or as we call it at
Google, the data space,
this'll be a good introduction
to some of the technologies
that we use in general when
we're working with this type
of data processing field.
So in this talk, I'm going to
get started by talking about
what a data pipeline is,
what do I mean by that.
And then we're going to
introduce you to some of
technologies involved with
building applications,
end-to-end data intensive
applications, using Google
technologies, including the App
Engine Pipeline API and
the MapReduce library
for App Engine.
We'll talk a little bit about
the App Engine Datastore and
Google BigQuery.
I'll show you that.
And then we'll talk a little
bit about Google
Cloud Storage as well.
Then we'll dive right
into some use cases.
I'm going to show you some
real use cases that we've
developed working with some
customers, some common use
cases for building data
applications on App Engine.
And finally best practices, I'll
talk a little bit about
performance.
And then we'll have
time for Q and A.
So let's get started.
Let me sort of set the stage.
And we'll get started with some
data application patterns.
So this is a use case we know
very well on the BigQuery team
working with Claritics, who I
think are in our Sandbox right
now, a social game analytics
company.
So mobile games and social games
generate a lot of data.
Web applications generate
a lot of data, as well.
You have many clients--
sometimes you have millions of
clients if a game goes
viral or a mobile
application goes viral--
generating data.
Playing games, leveling up,
buying new items, sending data
back to a web application
backend that you've developed.
And you're sometimes
sending data back
to the client itself.
And so, in these situations,
you're
generating a lot of data.
And it can grow immensely.
A lot of these applications
also need a place to store
that data and analyze that data
and visualize that data.
Think of a check
in application.
Some kind of application where
you're going somewhere--
geolocate yourself, maybe
at a business.
And you check in.
And that sends some data
to a web backend.
And then your application also
needs to make some sense of
this large amount of data.
Let's say you have millions of
users checking in all the
time, five times a day.
You're going to want to
visualize that data.
analyze that data.
And it is an immense
amount of data.
You could be generating
gigabytes of data
every single day.
So the two faces of this
application required different
optimizations.
So your client facing web
application stack needs to be
built for high availability
and performance.
You need to support millions
of users making dozens of
check ins a day or playing
millions of levels of your
game a day.
And that's going to generate a
lot of hits on your stack.
And you're also going
to want to push some
data back to them.
And then on your back end,
you're going to want to store
a lot of data, ask questions
about this data, run aggregate
queries over the data.
So there's different
optimizations for different
part of these applications.
Here's another application
pattern that you see a lot in
this space.
It's moving from unstructured
to structured data.
Or data that's structured in
some way, and you need to put
it into another format to
do something with, to
do some work with.
The canonical example
is web indexing.
HTML is originally a
presentation layer.
Millions, billions, trillions,
gazillions of web
pages on the internet--
Google crawls it every day and
creates an index of that.
So you can actually
search for things.
Other examples might be creating
Ngrams, doing word
counts, doing lexical analysis
of millions of things.
So you're taking data that's
structured in some way, or
unstructured, and you're doing
something with it, and turning
it into structured data.
So these are examples
of data pipelines.
In some cases, you can use the
same sort of software for the
same thing.
But let's take a closer look.
When your data is small--
when you just have 1 record,
1,000 records, 1 million
records, you can work with this
data on a local machine.
When your data's small enough,
you can work with your data on
your local machine, develop
locally, and then send your
software to a web application
stack.
And it'll scale well.
You can do queries using the
same software backend.
You can collect data using
the same backend.
But as your data gets large,
it creates challenges.
So what are some
scale problems?
When data sizes are small, yeah,
you can use MySQL for
everything.
But when it gets large, you have
to worry about the amount
of data you have overwhelming
the memory that you have
available or the storage
you have available.
You get into performance
problems.
So sometimes you have millions
of people using your web
application.
And it doesn't scale.
You need to shard
your database.
You need to have a distributed
system to make sure that this
works for you.
And what about asking questions
about your data?
When you're using a traditional
relational
database, and you need to run
aggregate queries, when you
get into the hundreds of
millions of rows, the
gigabytes and the terabytes,
sometimes it's impossible to
run such queries.
So basically, what I'm saying is
when you have massive data
sets, you need to find
the right optimal
technology for the task.
For example, for high
availability and performance,
you might want to use what
we call NoSQL database--
maybe a document data store or
a key value data store--
something that scales well and
is great on distributed
architecture.
And for analysis tools, you
might need an analysis tool
that's optimized for
aggregate queries.
And that might differ from
your NoSQL backend.
And finally, you might need
ubiquitous storage--
something that's great at
archiving, scaling--
and a place to store transformed
data, so a place
to store that structured data
that you just developed.
So let me talk to you
a little bit.
Before we get into pipelines.
And when I talk about pipelines,
I'm talking about
pipelining the data from
paradigm to paradigm, as
necessary, while
you're scaling.
But let's introduce
you to some of
Google's cloud services.
I just described a
NoSQL data store.
We have the App Engine
data store.
And hopefully, some of you
earlier were in a talk called
SQL verses NoSQL, where
we talked a
little bit about this.
But basically, this is a
key value data store.
It's highly available.
It's very high performance.
It allows for updating records,
creating records,
deleting records.
And it's got a fluid schema.
It's very easy to work with.
It's built for web scale
applications.
And it's built on a technology
we use internally at Google
called BigTable.
In fact, the whole point of
some of Google's cloud
services is to expose our
intrastructure to you
developers to use for your own
planetary or web scale
applications.
Like I said, for more
information about that--
I'm not going to dive too
deeply into data store.
But definitely check out the
video for SQL versus NoSQL.
I'm sure they figured out which
one is best and finally
settled the score.
Maybe next year we'll do a Vi
versus Emacs, and finally
settle that score as well.
OK.
So Google BigQuery , this is the
project that I'm currently
working on.
Google BigQuery is also an
externalization of an internal
software that we use
called Dremel.
And there's also a research
paper, just like BigTable,
about Dremel.
You can read about that.
So this allows you to write
SQL-like queries to analyze
massive structured,
semi-structured, data sets.
It uses a RESTful API.
It's an append-only
data store.
And unlike the App Engine
Datastore, it
uses a fixed schema.
So you can already see that
there's a difference between
these two data stores.
This is optimized for asking
questions about your data,
whereas Datastore is optimized
for collecting
and updating records.
So if you want to use these
together, there is a
difference there.
It's the schema difference.
Another one is that data
ingestion into BigQuery
requires a CSV format.
You have to stage your
data at CSV format.
That's fine.
So when we're building pipelines
to work with both of
these technologies, we're going
to need to convert data
store data first to CSV before
we use it with BigQuery.
And if you've never seen
BigQuery before, this might be
the first talk at I/O where
we're talking about BigQuery.
Let me just show you
a quick example.
So we have some public data
samples in BigQuery.
We have the Wikipedia
revision history.
You might have seen this
already, if you've seen us
talk about this.
Wikipedia revision history, up
until 2010, we're going to
update that with some
newer data.
So this is something like 300
million records, so kind of a
small data set.
So you can run things like--
just to give you an example of
what you can run, you can ask
questions like, what are the
top five articles based
on revision count?
So you may have seen
this already.
So we're querying over millions
and millions of
records, hundreds of millions
of records,
in just a few seconds.
Hang on one second.
Oh, there we go.
So it took 12 seconds.
But we just processed nine
gigabytes of data, hundreds of
millions of records.
And you can see, George W.
Bush is the most revised
Wikipedia article, followed
by WWE wrestling,
et cetera, et cetera.
And Michael Jackson rounds
out the top five.
All right.
So that's just an example of
how fast BigQuery is to ask
questions on aggregate
data sets.
I'm not going to talk too
much more about it.
We also have a couple demos.
I'm not going to show
you this demo.
You can see it in
another session.
But QlikView is a visualization
partner.
And they're actually building
dashboards with Big Query,
allowing you to run real time
analysis on massive data sets,
in this case, the American
birth statistics since
something like 1975.
And you can actually do
live queries on this.
And we'll show you this
in another session.
And let's see, this session will
be called Crunching Big
Data with BigQuery.
Definitely check it out.
It's going to be really fun.
I've seen the slides, and
it's going to be great.
My buddies Ryan and Jordan from
the BigQuery team will be
talking a little bit
more about that.
And finally, Google
Cloud Storage.
So Google Cloud Storage allows
you to store whatever you
want, unstructured data,
binary objects, huge
files in the cloud.
It integrates well with
Google App Engine.
So this is where we're going to
stage our large CSV files
before ingestion into BigQuery,
so when we actually
build our end to end
applications.
It's great.
It's very performant.
And it's easy to use.
OK.
So you remember before, I talked
about the different
paradigms, the different kinds
of technology, that are
optimized for different
aspects here.
So basically, for me, data
pipeline means that what we
want to do is move data
from paradigm
to paradigm to paradigm.
We want to use App Engine
Datastore to collect and serve
our web application, to collect
data, get back to the
client machine.
We want to use Google cloud
storage to store our archived
data, our raw data, the
structured transformations
from the Datastore,
and then Google
BigQuery to do the analysis.
So to me, a pipeline provides
a framework for automating
these data transfers.
And luckily, we have a great
library for App Engine called
the App Engine Pipeline API.
So this allows you to
automate workflows.
So it's built on top of App
Engine task queues.
And it abstracts away a lot of
the complexity of building
applications that take data from
one place, do something
with it, and move it
somewhere else.
So let's give a quick example.
This is the very simplest
example of using the Google
Pipeline API written
in Python.
It's the example we have
on our website.
It's called the add one class.
So in this case, what we're
going to do is we're going to
extend the pipeline API class.
And we're going to write a
function that just adds in
increments and integer.
And then the way we
use this is we
create a pipeline object.
And we just call the
start method.
This will start up a task that
will run this pipeline and
return a pipeline ID.
And we can refer to that ID,
and see if the pipeline has
completed its task, which
in this case is
incrementing a number.
It's pretty simple.
This is as simple
as you can go.
And then once we-- we're going
to check that pipeline and see
if it's done.
And if it's done, we're going
to print out the value.
So basically, if
it's finalized,
print out the value.
So you can see in just a few
lines of code, we've actually
created sort of an asynchronous
data pipeline,
where all we need to do
is feed it a number.
And it will give us a result
based on the transformation
that we're employing, which
is just increment.
The other cool thing about the
pipeline API is you can
connect two pipelines
together.
You can take the output
from one and pipe that
into another pipeline.
So in this case, I've actually
taken that add one pipeline,
and I'm piping the result from
the first pipeline into
another add one pipeline.
So basically, it's add two.
So I take the first step.
I get a result.
And then once the result
is done, I yield that.
I generate the value.
And I put it into the
pipeline again.
So here's an example.
This is actually the code
that I just showed you.
I added a little Ajax
query, so you
can just see it working.
It's pretty trivial.
Let's see.
Somebody pick a number.
I heard you say 42.
Great.
Let's see if the demo gods
are favoring me today.
Oh, 43, OK.
So what this is doing is it's
just calling that code I just
showed you.
It's just taking this
number, it's sending
it to an App Engine.
This is actually an App Engine
application running live.
I'm sending it to an App Engine
application, starting
the pipeline, checking every
second to see if it's done.
When it's done, return
the number.
And of course, we
have add two.
So you can add two to
the number, 123.
And there you go.
So this is an example
of the code I just
showed you running live.
The other cool thing about the
pipeline API is you can just
start up pipelines
asynchronously.
I could run two at once.
So I can say, one and
five or four.
And I can run these
at the same time.
So these can all be running
asynchronously.
So basically, with just a
little bit of code, I've
actually created a workflow.
I've created a workflow that
increments integers.
Now this is probably overkill
for incrementing integers.
You're using the power
of Google's clouds
to increment a number.
But this sort of illustrates
what we can do with this API.
OK.
So the pipeline API--
a couple more things to
say about it is--
it lets you write these kind
of distributed asynchronous
workflows using procedural
code.
I can literally just
say, start here.
Move the data here.
Do this.
And then the result will be x.
It kind of lets you define
sources and syncs--
and we'll show you a little
bit with that later--
where your inputs can
be a certain thing.
It can be a number.
You can get input from
the Datastore.
files or from the
BlobStore in App Engine.
And I'll show you this
a little later too.
It provides a useful dashboard
for viewing your progress,
because when you kick off a
pipeline, it's running on App
Engine task queues in
the background.
And so, you may not see--
it's hard to see what's
going on.
Of course, you can go to the App
Engine control panel, and
check out the task
queues there.
But this provides you a cool
dashboard to sort of see
what's going on.
So we talked a little bit about
the pipeline API for
developing work flows.
But what about that whole
transformation step?
If I have gigabytes of data, how
am I going to distribute
the transformation across
a number of machines
to make it go fast?
And what can I add to this
framework, or let's say map to
this framework, to reduce the
pain of dealing with this?
Well, MapReduce, of course.
So MapReduce is an
abstraction.
It's a powerful abstraction for
dealing with distributed
data processing.
We use it extensively
at Google.
And it's used all over in
open source movement
implementations built into all
kinds of data processing
applications.
And I'm going to show you
the MapReduce 101.
But basically, it's a way to
take certain kinds of data
processing tasks and distribute
them to multiple
machines, to break them down
and to run them all in
parallel to get them
done faster.
So the Hello World
of MapReduce is--
I'm sure some of you know this,
but in case you're not
familiar with it-- the
Hello World of
MapReduce is word counts.
Word count lends itself really
well to MapReduce, because
it's easy to distribute
the tasks into
individual work units.
So you can actually send them
off into individual nodes, and
then aggregate the
results later.
So of course, the first step of
a MapReduce word count is
to have a collection
of documents.
Three documents is not a lot.
But you might be doing this on
300 million documents or the
entire web.
The first step is a map phase.
This is a very simplistic
view of MapReduce.
But really, this is all
there is to it.
The first step is a map phase.
We're going to map through
each document.
And we're going to do an
individual word count.
What we're going to do is we're
going to emit a key
value pair.
One, the key, will
be the word.
And the value will be
the word count of
an individual document.
So we'll send each document
through this function to map
through it.
And it will go through
a shuffle phase.
And this is sort of the magic
computationally intensive part
of MapReduce, where we're
going to aggregate
the results by key.
So we're going to put all
the hellos in one place.
And we're going to take all the
worlds, and put them in
another place.
And so, we're going to sort
through the data by key.
And finally, we're going to
aggregate the result.
We're going to go through what
we call a reduce phase.
And we're going to take all
the individual hello--
the dictionary that we created
with hello and the dictionary
we created with world-- and
we're going to sum up the
results, and then provide you
with, well, here's the final
word count.
The first step, sometimes we
call this the fan out, where
we're mapping through and we're
fanning this out to
multiple machines.
And the reduce step, sometimes
we call that the fan in.
And as you can see here, this
really lends itself well to
distributive processing, because
each individual unit,
each individual little
box here, can be
on a separate machine.
And when you have hundreds of
millions of documents to
process, farming this out to
many, many nodes really helps,
many workers.
So that's basically--
it seems simple.
But what's not simple about this
is when I kind of hinted
with the shuffle sort.
What's not simple is
coordinating all of these
different units, waiting for one
process to end before you
get to the next one.
Keeping track of each of
the individual workers.
All of this is very complex.
And when you're dealing with
a huge distributed network,
that's where the kind of
MapReduce framework and all of
these open source libraries
around MapReduce are really
solving this distribution
problem.
So as I just said, there's
not just Hadoop.
But there's actually lots
of open source MapReduce
implementations out there.
And here's another one.
The App Engine MapReduce
library.
So App Engine has a MapReduce
library built on top of the
pipeline's API that lets you
distribute your data
processing task across
many machines.
So it's open source.
It's built on top
of task queues.
And it stores individual data so
that every time you do one
of these aggregations,
there's an individual
data processing step.
And the result of those steps
is stored in BlobStore.
And of course, all the workflows
are coordinated with
the pipeline API.
I showed you the add one pipe,
where I'm just taking data
from one place and piping
it through to another.
This really coordinates
a lot of activity.
So you have the shuffle
sort, and the reduce,
and the mapper phase.
And these are all being
coordinated with the
pipeline's API.
What's amazing is, using the
pipeline's API as a framework
for the Google App Engine
MapReduce, the amount of code
you have to write to coordinate
these kinds of
tasks is really, really small.
And I'll show you right now
what it looks like.
So remember our add one pipe
code, where I was just saying,
here is an input, do something
with it, and
then yield a result?
An App Engine MapReduce
pipeline is
built on top of that.
And it looks kind
of like this.
It looks like a lot of code.
But actually, it's
pretty trivial.
The first thing you need is
just a name of the step.
So this is going to be the name
of the pipeline step.
And in the MapReduce
pipeline, we're
going to call two functions.
We're going to call
a mapper function
and a reducer function.
And in this particular
implementation, you don't have
to worry about your
shuffle sort.
It'll run the shuffle
sort by itself.
So the mapper function-- for
example, the word count, maybe
the mapper function is counting
each individual word,
and then yielding that
key value pair
that I talked about.
And then the reduce will take
all the intermediate steps and
aggregate them together.
The other thing you can define--
if you can see it
here-- is a source.
So in this case, I'm asking
it to pull out
data from the Datastore.
And we have a Datastore
input reader.
Actually, we have lots of input
and output readers.
And then I'm saying, sink the
data into the Google Cloud
Storage, which is our
file output writer.
And that can also write
to BlobStore.
We have other input,
output readers.
We have readers that can read
compressed data out of BlobStore.
If those of you who were in
the code lab this morning
about this, we also have an
App Engine logs reader.
So there's all kinds of ways you
can read data in and out.
And then we can send
the parameters to
the custom map parameter.
Maybe there's a particular--
for example, I want to tell
the Datastore reader which
entity to read out
of Datastore.
There might be different
things.
And for the reducer, I
might want to say--
or I do need to say--
which Google Cloud Storage
bucket I want to use.
So you can just send those as a
list or a dictionary to the
mapper functions.
And then shards, you can
tell this pipeline how
many workers to run.
This is going to be
how many tasks get
spun up on App Engine.
It doesn't necessarily correlate
with instances.
And I'll talk about that
later in the end.
And finally, this can be
your whole pipeline.
And that could run and dump the
resulting data into Google
Cloud Storage.
But you can also pipe this
to another pipeline.
So I can say, when this is done,
then take that result
and do something else with it,
and do something else with it.
I talked to a couple people
internally at Google who are
using this same process for
some ad related stuff.
And they're doing like four,
five, six joins, piping the
results here, doing this,
doing another MapReduce.
It's pretty complex.
But it's really easy to define
these using this API.
So I'm going to show you
some real code from
some real use cases.
But before I go on, I just want
to talk about why use
Google App Engine when you
have all sorts of other
choices for data processing
tasks.
So first and foremost, scaling
things can be really time
consuming and difficult,
especially if you're moving
from that relational database on
a web, like a LAMPStack, to
something different, because
you're moving
from software to software.
Sometimes you're moving
from hosting provider
to something else.
And you have to learn how to use
the new software, optimize
it, worry about the pitfalls
of tuning.
That can be time consuming
and expensive.
So no need to buy new hardware
infrastructures.
A common pattern, actually, that
I've seen, working with
customers, is that they'll have
some web application,
then they'll put the data
internally into some internal
data center, and then pipe
that data somewhere else.
And all those things
are time consuming.
And there's lots of places
where that can fail.
And a lot of places where
you need to optimize
those kind of pipes.
And so, doing everything
on App Engine
really simplifies that.
It's easy to kind of
predict your costs.
I always maintain that when
you move from software
paradigm to software paradigm,
from relational to NoSQL,
there's a cost there of
unpredictable cost.
Because you don't know how well
the particular software
will perform with
your use case.
Or you may not know how best
to tune your stack.
So there are always
unpredictable costs when you
move from system to system.
And finally, App Engine
is a great
application development framework.
It's a scalable web application
stack, like
everything you need to build
a web app is there.
So if you're writing a game and
you want to collect data
for that game, analyze the data,
serve it back to your
customers or your players,
something like that,
everything you need is there.
So you've got the web
application stack.
You've got the Datastore.
You can do analysis
with BigQuery,
Cloud Storage for archiving.
We provide a lot of things.
And so it's just a great
place to be to
write a web scale app.
And it really just simplifies
development.
That's why I like to use it.
All right.
So let's look at these
in practice.
I'm going to show you some
actual code and some things
that we've built just to sort
of test out these ideas.
And also from working with
customers, I'll show you some
of the typical use cases.
I'll actually show you
two, in particular.
So the first one is just a
simple data store mapper.
Since I'm on the BigQuery team,
a lot of my time is
spent worrying about how to
get large amounts, like
gigabytes and terabytes,
of data into
BigQuery for analysis.
It's not as simple
as it seems.
A lot of people don't have
terabytes of data.
But a lot of people have a
lot of data in Datastore.
And so I get this question
all the time.
How do I take my data and
convert it into something that
can used with BigQuery easily?
So in this case, we're going to
convert Datastore data from
the App Engine Datastore into,
first, a CSV file.
And then we're going to ingest
that into BigQuery.
And we're also going to do a
really simple transformation.
We're going to transform
a timestamp.
So BigQuery supports four data
types, integer, floating
point, Boolean, and string.
It doesn't have a unique
date time stamp.
So date formats in BigQuery
should be converted to Unix
Epoch time stamps
or into integer.
But Datastore data can support
different kinds of time stamps
and also different data types.
So oftentimes, we have
to convert that data.
It's a pretty trivial
transformation.
But it lends itself great for
MapReduce when you're building
these kind of applications.
So just to simplify,
we're going to
take Datastore entities.
We're going to transform them,
put them in the Cloud Storage,
and then pipe them into Google
BigQuery at the end.
In this case, I wrote a little
sample app that uses an App
Engine backend to collect
Google + statuses.
I'm actually just collecting the
date it was published, the
person who published it, the
URL, and the summary-- we call
it the title-- the summary
of the post.
So I wrote this little
backend.
It just collects.
It's running on a chron.
Like every five minutes,
it collects
some data from Google+.
In fact, you can do
it yourself with
the Google APIs Explorer.
I'll show you which
API call I used.
First, let me authorize
myself.
Looks good.
So this is an online API.
You can use this yourself.
Actually, it's on the Google
Developer site.
So I'm going to run a query for
any Google+ posts recently
that mention Google.
Hopefully, there's one or two.
So the JSON response looks
kind of like this.
Yeah, I'm just collecting the
URL and, I think, the
name and the title.
So title's like a summary
of the post, itself.
It's not all the text.
And I'm taking that every
five minutes.
And I'm dumping it into
the data store.
So I'm kind of creating this
chron job streaming thing.
You can do this with
any Datastore data.
If you have a mobile application
and people are
checking in, you could just use
App Engine, collect those
check ins, dump them into
Datastore continuously.
So that's basically what
I'm doing there.
So that's piping
into Datastore.
And then what I want to do is
take all that Datastore data--
I actually didn't collect a lot,
because I want this demo
to run fast enough
for this talk.
If you've got gigabytes and
gigabytes of data, it might
take a few minutes to do
these kind of MapReduce
transformations.
But I want to transform that
data from Datastore into Cloud
Storage, into a CSV format.
And then, once that's done, once
that workflow is done, I
want to pipe that data
into Google BigQuery.
So that's the end of
my data pipeline.
For you BI people out there,
this is sort of a classic
extract, transform,
load operation.
This is kind of the business
lingo for BI when they talk
about taking data from different
data silos, and then
transforming it into something
they can work with, and then
loading it into another
application.
Because oftentimes, the data
you collect in a large
business is siloed across
multiple data stores.
So this is one way--
this is sort of an example of
that kind of transformed to
this sort of data pipeline
paradigm.
And we'll talk a little bit
about a more complex silo
problem in the next example.
All right.
So here's the code.
So I created something called
the iterator pipeline.
It's doing almost exactly
what I described before.
But there's no reduce phase.
I'm just mapping through every
single Datastore data entity.
I'm doing a simple
transformation on that record.
And I'm just dumping it
into a large file in
Google Cloud Storage.
So I've defined a
iterator, a map.
This is actually the
mapper pipeline.
It's another one of
the pipelines in
the MapReduce library.
It doesn't have a
reduce phase.
So it's slightly simpler.
And I'm telling it to put the
data into a Google storage
bucket that I control.
I'm saying output
sharding none.
That just means it's going
to make one big file.
You can say one big file or one
file per worker, if you
want to do that.
And then at the end, I'm saying
yield the result to
this other pipeline that I
created called Google Cloud
Storage to BigQuery.
And here's the transformation
I'm trying to do.
That's the time stamp,
that format, that
comes out of Google+.
It's like a UTC timestamp.
I want to transform it into a
Unix Epoch timestamp, which
looks like that.
It's just a big integer.
And so I'm incorporating a super
simple transformation.
So every record, I'm looking
for that time stamp.
And I'm just converting it.
And that's it.
And here's the Cloud Storage
to BigQuery pipeline.
So this is just another
pipeline.
Once all of that stuff is done
and the file has been created,
the CSV file, I'm going to kick
off this new pipeline.
So this is what's great about
the pipelines API is that it
lets you finish your job before
kicking off another one.
So once everything is done, all
the data's been mapped out
of Datastore and saved in the
files API, I'm going to kick
off this ingestion job
into BigQuery.
So here's an example.
This is actual data from
the Datastore.
Hopefully, it's large enough
for you can read.
I just pulled out some random
ones to display here in this
App Engine app.
You can see the data format,
Late Show with Craig Ferguson,
something about Morgan
Freeman.
There's Lotus F1 team has
something to say.
So this is just random data
I collected from Google+.
So let's see if this'll work.
I'm also going to open up my
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
So this is the bucket where I'm
going to dump the data.
So right now it's empty.
And let me just make sure
it's still empty.
So let's kick this
pipeline off.
We're going to move some data.
Here is the dashboard
that I talked about.
Looks complex, don't worry
about all the details.
I'm just going to show
you what it's doing.
So this is going to start
the pipeline.
And just like my little simple
pipeline example-- where I had
the little spinner, and it was
checking to see-- this is
doing kind of the same thing,
but on a larger scale.
It's showing me which phase
of the pipeline
it's on right now.
And it's refreshing like every
10 seconds or something.
Let me auto refresh it.
OK.
So now the entire pipeline
is done.
I only had a few thousand
entities in there, I think.
So basically, it went through
each pipeline, my iterator.
It mapped through the data.
And then it piped the
result into Google
Cloud Storage to BigQuery.
So that's pretty much it.
You can inspect each
individual thing.
I think I had 16 shards
for this function.
It shows you how much data
each shard processed.
So they're not equivalent,
because it was just grabbing
data out of the Datastore
and how long it took.
It took, whatever, 13
seconds to run that.
And then I can look here.
And this is the object in
cloud storage that it's
working on to pipe
into BigQuery.
So let's go back to
Cloud Storage and
see if this is complete.
Let me refresh.
So there it is.
Let me grab that real fast.
And you can just take
a look at it.
Let's open it with Vi.
So can you see that?
So as you can see, it's
just the same data.
But it's now CSV format.
And I've converted all the
timestamps to Unix Epoch.
OK, great.
So that looks good.
The BigQuery ingestion step
takes a minute or two, because
we stage the data in Google
Cloud Storage.
And we tell BigQuery
to grab it.
And it batches it and ingests
it into a format we can do
queries on.
That might take a minute.
I'm not going to wait for that
step if it's still running.
But OK, it looks like-- let me
just refresh this real fast.
But I did this yesterday just
to have-- oh, there it is.
It's already done.
So this is actually done.
I think it's this one.
So here it is.
So it's actually ingested
all those entities.
There were only a
few thousand.
But it's ingested all those
entities into BigQuery.
And I can look at it
and see the data.
And I can run queries.
I could run a query like,
what are the top
five people that post?
Like, who are the biggest
posters, things like that.
Actually, let's just
run that real fast.
So this is called
Datastore data.
So I'm just writing
a quick query.
I didn't know what the name of
my newly created table was,
because I named it after
the time stamp, the
current time stamp.
So let's just do like the
top posts where the post
contains the word--
I don't know--
Google.
Let's see if there's
even any in here.
Ignore case.
The top, and let's call--
let's do the
names, the top name.
Top five name and the count
from there, let's see
if that will work.
Oh, thank you.
Good eyes, everyone.
All right.
There you go.
The Hangout Show mentions
Google a lot.
They probably say--
I don't know what The
Hangout Show is.
But I'm assuming it's some kind
of Google hangout show.
And they're probably saying,
join our Google hangout.
And The Crisis Show
on Google Hangout.
I don't want to watch that.
I know what that is.
Anyway, so there's an example.
So I've just built a data
pipeline application.
Now imagine if I was collecting
lots and lots of data.
I was collecting all the Google+
posts from everybody I
know or collecting
data from a game.
So I could collect lots
of data from a game.
I'm a developer.
My analyst for my company comes
up and says, at what
point-- at what level do people
drop off and go play
another game?
And I could pipe that data into
BigQuery and tell them
with my application, which
is also the backend
for my mobile game.
So you can sort of see how you
can use this sort of MapReduce
and Pipelines libraries
to build this.
So we had a code lab this
morning, actually, that showed
you how to do exactly what I did
but with App Engine logs.
The slides of this presentation
will be on the website.
So you can actually refer
to this later.
But the code lab is here.
And you can kind of check
out how to do it.
It's very cool.
OK, here's another example.
This is a more complex
example.
This is another example
everybody asks me about.
It's how to join two siloed data
stores into a single data
store or database
by a unique key.
So imagine two data
store entities.
So you have an App Engine data
store entity called products.
And this is a list or a catalog
of all the products
that you're selling.
So in this case, I have
an example of
self driving glasses.
I don't know why I wrote that,
self driving glasses
manufactured by Google.
And it has unique ID three.
So this is your product--
your database of the warehouse
or your description of what
you're selling.
And for sales, you've got
every time one of these
products is sold, you also
have that unique ID.
You have the store
that it sold at.
And you have the date
and a bunch of other
information, of course.
But oftentimes, these are
in different places.
And you want to put
them in one place.
BigQuery is really great at
analyzing data that's in a
single denormalized database.
So this is kind of a normalized
database, where you
might have one thing
per record.
In BigQuery, you can have a
sparse database with redundant
values and nulls.
And it works really well on
single table data, where you
don't have to run a join.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take this data, I'm
going to join in on that
key, which is the SKU.
It's the product identification
number.
I'm going to take all that data
and join it together.
And then I'm going to write
it out to a file that
BigQuery can use.
This is one example where the
workflow diagram is more
complicated than the
actual code.
So I'll show you the
workflow diagram.
This is a lot like the
MapReduce sample
I showed you before.
So the first step I'm going to
do is map through each of
these separately.
I'm going to create two mapper
pipelines that are separate.
And the first mapper pipeline
is going to go through the
Datastore entities.
And it's going to pull out
a key and a value.
And the key will be that
product identification.
And the value is going to
be all the other data.
I'm just going to treat
it as a big string.
I'm going to write it out
as a big CSV string.
And I'm going to do that with
the sales database, as well.
So I'll have two different
aggregate mappers.
But the thing that's similar
between them is the key.
There'll be a unique
key for each one.
I'm going to do this
big shuffle sort.
And I'm going to aggregate
them by key.
So I'm going to take all the ID
ones, and I'm going to put
them in one place, ID twos
and put them in one
place, and ID threes.
And this is another example
of a great for distributed
processing.
So I'm doing these big joins.
I'm going to let a different
worker work on
each of these processes.
So this is a great way to
do distributed work.
And then my reduce step, I'm
going to take all the
aggregates.
And I'm going to, for each
individual node in this step,
for each one of these,
I'm going to
concatenate them together.
So I'm going to say for every
key one product, I'm going to
join it together with every
other sales example.
I'm going to dump that into a
big CSV file, and stick it
into BigQuery.
It looks very complicated.
The code is much simpler
than the flow chart.
The code looks like this.
Two data store mappers--
just like I showed you before--
iterate through the
data store.
I'm going to call this pipeline
join on SKU, because
that's what I'm doing.
I'm going to do something
called-- with the pipeline,
I'm going to use a class called
extend or a method
called extend.
And I'm going to take both
mapper outputs, and I'm going
to dump them into a new output
called all data.
It's really simple.
So basically, I'm taking two
data streams, and I'm piping
the results together
in something
I'm calling all data.
And then I'm going to send
that to the shuffle sort.
I'm going to say, shuffle sort,
take all of this data
and do whatever magic thing
that you do with it.
Take all the files generated by
all data and shuffle them.
Aggregate them by key.
And finally, I'm going to take
the result and stick it into a
reduce pipeline.
And that looks a lot
like the other
pipelines you've seen before.
It's just going to run a reduce
function over all that
aggregate data, and then dump
the result into Google Cloud
Storage bucket in CSV format.
And then my reduce function
looks like-- well,
I ran out of space.
But it can be anything
you want.
You can actually do a join.
But this is also great
for aggregate count.
You might want to see for every
item what store sold the
most per item.
And if you're a huge retailer
or you're a retailer working
with loyalty cards or even if
you're somebody who's a game
maker, you can use this kind of
processing to do these huge
data processing tasks
and answer these
really difficult questions.
So you could do a count.
I'm going to do a join.
You name it.
So let's look at it now.
This is another example.
This is actual data from an
App Engine app that I just
randomly made stuff up.
Here is Nexus tablet and Android
Jellybeans, and here
are the manufacturers.
So these are the IDs
of the actual data.
And here are where
they were sold.
So item number one, the
Galaxy Nexus, was
sold at the web store.
And item number four, YouTube
t-shirt, was sold at the New
York store.
Similar data connected by ID but
in different datastores.
OK, so let's run this pipeline,
and see what it
looks like.
Demo gods?
Yes, there we go.
So it looks a little
more complicated
than the one before.
The one before, we really
had just two steps.
It was like map and
then dump it into.
This one is running
two data store
mappers at the same time.
Let me refresh this manually.
So it's already finished one.
There's not a lot of data
in this App Engine app.
But basically it's
running both.
And it's coordinating
the streams into a
single shuffle step.
So you don't have to do--
all the code that I showed you
was really the entire code for
this application-- besides the
little like the Chrome that
actually holds the application
together--
that's all you need to write.
And the pipelines API and the
MapReduce library take care of
all the rest.
So it's already done with it.
It's just mapped through
the datastore.
It's sent both of
those streams.
It's extending them to
the shuffle sort.
It's running that now.
This might take about
a minute.
But once it's done with the
shuffle service, it's going to
kick off the reduce step
all by itself.
And hopefully, at the end of
this we'll have a new CSV file
in Google Cloud Storage.
And while this is running, I'm
just going to say, I've kicked
off all of these MapReduce jobs
by clicking on a button,
which is a valid way
to do things.
You can also automate this
stuff of course.
You could run a chron job that
kicks off a nightly MapReduce
pipeline and does all these
things automatically.
And that's probably what a
lot of people would do
when they use this.
The other thing you can do is
you can stop these in the
middle or emit messages
during the pipeline.
Like when one pipeline
is complete, you can
send an email out.
You could update the web app.
There's all kinds of ways you
can use these to have a better
user experience for people who
are interacting with these
things through the apps.
So this is going to
run for a while.
I don't want to take
up too much time.
We can actually come back to
this in just a second.
Let's go to the next slide.
And I'll pop back over
here and see how the
MapReduce is going.
It's going to take
another minute.
OK, so performances and
best practices, here's
what you can adjust.
I already talked about
the shards per job.
So shards just corresponds
to tasks or workers.
It does not necessarily
correspond to instances.
App Engine scales for you.
And it'll choose the
amount of what we
call front end instances.
Those are basically sort of
analogous to a node or a
computer running on a
distributed network to
fulfill that job.
So when you kick off a task,
it may spin up several
instances with many tasks
running on each instance.
Or if your job is
computationally intensive, it
might actually spin up more
instances to handle it.
But that's the thing
you adjust.
And I think it's best to try to
use as few as possible for
the data you're using.
But if you spin up many, many
tasks-- like, for example, say
I want to run this process with
15 shards or 20 shards--
it's going to take longer than
running a distributive process
with 500 shards.
So you can actually
control that.
You can also control that to
kind of stay under a quota.
If you're trying to do a daily
quota, and you don't want to
burst and do you like six
million datastore reads per
hour, or whatever.
You can adjust that.
You can also adjust
instance size.
You probably don't have
to do this much.
But occasionally, you'll run
into a computational task that
uses up all the memory on
a front end instance.
And you might need to bump
up to a higher instance.
You shouldn't have to worry
about that too much.
If you're doing document
processing, like large
documents, that may happen.
And then task queue settings,
since this is all based on
task queues, you can tweak
the task queues somewhat.
Say I want to have more task
queues running at a particular
time or just the refresh
rate or what have you.
OK, let's go back to this and
see if it's still running.
OK, it's done.
So this thing is done.
It took about a minute,
two minutes.
Let's go to Google Cloud
Storage, see if
there's a new file.
OK, there is.
Let me grab that.
And let me open this one up.
So there it is.
Yeah, there wasn't much data
in there to begin with.
But we've taken all that data
from different data stores,
and we've munged it
together into CSV.
I didn't add the cloud storage
to BigQuery pipe.
But it's trivial to add that.
I can just type this data into
BigQuery very simply.
So that is an example
of the join.
All right.
OK, one more thing
to talk about.
We have something internally
called--
experimental for you
developers to use--
experimental high performance
shuffle.
We call it the BigShuffle.
When your data gets really
large, like gigabytes and
gigabytes of records, I told
you about the shuffle sort.
It's computationally
intensive.
So BigShuffle is a way to use
our shuffle infrastructure to
run these big shuffle sorts.
Normally, all of the stuff
is in user space
or App Engine space.
But sometimes, you need more
power to do these massive
shuffle sorts, where
all of those
aggregates are being built.
And sorting is happening
for your MapReduce job.
So anyway, we're currently
accepting a limited amount of
BigShuffle testers.
I'll update these slides
if you're interested.
Or you can just come to me and
talk to me about how to become
one of these shuffle testers.
But I'll put a link for you to
fill out your information on
this slide on the Google
I/O website.
So you can actually
try it out.
If you've got a lot of data,
we'd love to talk to you.
And we'd love you to try out
this shuffle service, and
build a pipeline that takes
advantage of our
infrastructure.
Let me go back.
So let me just wrap up.
I stole this from another talk,
from Jordan's talk,
who's sitting right here.
But build so that your
computation is close to where
your data lives.
I think this is a good adage.
This really helps you build
these end to end pipelines and
make them efficient.
When you're dealing with data
that's all in the web.
It's all in the same place.
It's all being computed on by
a single software entity.
Worry about your app and not
your infrastructure.
You guys are software
developers.
Some of you may be hardware
developers or building clusters.
But if you're a software
developer building a web app--
building a game, building a
mobile device, a backend for
your Android app--
you want to worry
about the app.
You don't want to worry about
all this infrastructure.
So these libraries and all of
this technology that we're
offering for you is to help
you build this stuff.
And finally, the code
is so simple.
Keep it simple.
Keep it easy to maintain
and easy to test.
So that's what we're going for
here is to help you do that.
So I'll leave you with that.
And if you guys have any
questions, now's the time.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Cool.
So remind me.
Do people come up to the
mike for questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes, they do.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
All right.
So there's a microphone set up
if you have any questions.
AUDIENCE: If you have a large
process running, let's say, in
the pipeline you've got
like five steps.
And let's say the first
two steps use a lot of
computational resources.
At the third step, you
have a failure.
How do you restart your pipeline
from the third step
so you're not redoing those
first two steps?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
So there's different ways
you can do that.
I've actually been playing
with this.
One way is that you store the
aggregate steps in the
BlobStore or in Google
Cloud Storage.
You can actually do that.
So I would recommend if you're
running a huge task to do not
delete some of those
intermediate steps.
The MapReduce pipeline actually
has a cleanup phase.
But you don't have
to run that.
You can actually run this,
and then save the
aggregate steps in--
I would use Google Cloud
Storage for that.
AUDIENCE: But the pipeline
itself doesn't have any type
of mechanism to restart from a
different step and say-- you
know, so you see the failure
at step three.
And you come in the next day,
let's say, you resolve that.
And it doesn't have
a way to restart?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
It depends on
what the failure is.
So if failures are network
failures or something that's
recoverable, it will actually
try to recover itself.
It won't abort the process
completely.
If it's something like the data
itself is in a format
that the next step can't use
or you've done something
completely wrong, then we don't
have a mechanism to
restart that way.
Thank you very much for
coming to this talk.
And catch me afterwards if
you have more questions.